So we've now learned of a child in Iowa who
has died of Corona virus complications.
And this was the first death of a miner there
during the pandemic.
And meanwhile, schools are opening today in
Iowa.
Now, there are schools in Iowa that decided
we're going to go remote for now, or at least
they thought they decided it because then
the governors, the governor of Iowa, came
in and is actually forcing some schools to
open.
So there's about three or four different stories
here.
One is this is exactly why lots of places
try to make it illegal or at least a violation
of contracts for teachers to go on strike
so that when the governor says jump, instead
of saying, why are we jumping?
That doesn't make sense.
They say, how high?
And this is exactly an example of that.
It relates to collective bargaining.
It relates to unions.
It relates to so many different things on
the labor side.
But it's not our focus today.
The other side of it is really the craziness
of of the pandemic and the entire story of
opening and school openings and the like.
And the really crazy thing about the school
starting fiasco is that it's all becoming
laughably political.
And I want to be careful about saying laughably
because people's lives are at stake here.
But what I mean is it's obviously political
because we're now only talking about a couple
of months.
It's just that they are months that are crucial
to Donald Trump's reelection and possibly
to the reelections of Republicans in the House,
in the Senate gubernatorial Republican reelections.
And I'll explain what I mean by that and be
really specific.
You have people on the right like Trump, but
many Republican governors, although Charlie
Baker here in Massachusetts has been good
on this Republican senators, you have all
these people saying open the schools now,
open it for economic reasons, open it for
mental health reasons.
You know, being closed leads to suicides and
mental health issues and isolation and all
of this stuff.
OK, there gambit is schools being open will
help them get reelected, particularly trump.
The idea being the optics of schools being
open is good politically.
It'll seem like things are returning to normal
in advance of the November election and there
is a truth to it.
I don't deny that there's an economic reality
here where many parents can't work or can't
work as much as they normally would if their
kids are in school because they're essentially
counting on school for childcare.
They are in jobs.
Thanks to our economy that don't pay enough
for them to be able to say, okay, I'll pay
for childcare and then go to work.
The numbers don't make sense.
So I'm completely sensitive to that.
And these are real issues.
I'm not brushing off the issue of opening
schools as something that we shouldn't even
consider in some places.
There are counties that have almost no cases,
and in particular, there are these sort of
semi rural schools where you might have like
seven through twelve, might have 150 kids.
Right, 25 kids per class.
You can do that relatively safely.
And I'm not against doing that.
The problem is that's not the case in a variety
of places that are opening where we've instantly
seen cases spread, quarantines start, et cetera.
And again, it's almost September at this point.
We're talking about one semester.
Had we done.
It's always too little, too late.
Had we done a full coordinated shutdown in
the spring, two months, maybe three full mass
compliance, we would look like many countries,
which now we're doing well and we wouldn't
be having this conversation to the degree
that we are having.
It would be clear there's a bunch of schools
that can open, but now everything has to stay
open.
Things the guidelines are ignored.
Schools must open.
And we're in a position where, for political
reasons, Donald Trump and others want to force
schools open.
And we saw what happened.
We looked at Georgia.
We looked at Missouri.
We're looking at Iowa, Indiana.
Everywhere, kids and teachers start getting
sick.
Entire classes have to be quarantined for
weeks.
You're essentially ending up sending a whole
bunch of people home anyway.
It would be far more logical, although maybe
not politically beneficial to say let's do
this semester remote.
We're not saying no school.
We're not saying no school for a long time.
If things go well, we are hopefully, hopefully
just a couple of months from some vaccine
approval optimistically, which by the end
of the year, some more significant number
of people will be able to start getting.
And in the spring semester, things will start
to normalize with.
It will still take time.
But right now, the debate is over just a few
months.
And what is the real obstacle?
For many parents?
It's the money piece.
Other countries have said, let's be safe and
let's really send people money and take care
of people.
The.
Long run benefit suggests it's warranted in
the U.S. it took months to get one 12 hundred
dollar payment to people.
Who knows if and when the next one is going
to come?
And that creates this problem.
It's the same with the desire from many on
the right to cut the unemployment benefits.
If you do that, you're going to force people
back to work, not safely necessarily, but
it will create a semblance of normalcy.
So they will frame it as the left wants everything
closed forever.
The left wants everything closed until November
4th just to hurt Trump.
Right.
One of these two.
It's almost September.
We're talking about like three months.
Now, just do school from home.
We'll get to winter break.
And then hopefully by then, some portion of
the population will start to be vaccinated.
We'll be starting to get beyond the halfway
point of flu season.
We're all going to be better off without having
to re shut down because things explode.
That's disastrous.
Economically flu season coming.
I got my flu shot Friday.
Glad to have it.
Dr. Foushee recently said this won't go on
forever, but we have to be safe until we get
to the other side.
And now Iowa, which opens schools today with
the first confirmed child corona virus death.